[Music]
foreign
the Press preview our first look of
course of what's on the front pages as
they arrive and it's time to see what's
making the headlines with Rachel gunlith
and Andrew Pierce they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages and the eye has the headline
Tories in open revolts against prime
minister as backbenchers confront trusts
with anger during today's funeral
1922 meeting
political turmoil also covered by the
guardian the paper says trust faces new
Peril as Tories go on the attack over
economy
rip up your tax plan's top officials
urge trust deepening political divides
also shown by the times that's also on
the front of the mirror which leads with
you turn or you go
the express also leads on Tori anger and
tells of MPS attacking the bank of
England governor for stupid comments
the financial times also leads with this
mounting political pressure as the
conservative leader faces a backlash
from Tory MPS to rewrite unfunded tax
cut plans
blue wall Falls that's on the front of
the Metro is a new poll predicts that
dozens of conservatives could lose their
seats at the next general election the
telegraph has the latest from Buckingham
Palace the headline coronation Rao looms
over crown for queen
and that story is also featured in The
Daily Mail Lake question could Camilla
have to swap her crown
and the scar tells of the cost of
loathing crisis revealing new details on
couples who have spit up but can't
afford to move out because of the
economic woes
and just to remind you that by scanning
the QR code you'll see on the screen
join the program there it is you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers why don't you watch us talking
about them and we're joined of course
tonight by Rachel canliff and Andrew
Pierce so let's dive straight in now
welcome to both let's have a look then
at the eye many papers leading on this
uh the I says Tori is an open revolt
against the Prime Minister Rachel
apparently that meeting this evening
between the Prime Minister and the back
bench conservative 1922 committee did
not go well
no it hasn't really been a great day for
Liz truss uh it actually started before
that meeting with her second ever pmqs
because what were
um the the death of the queen and the
morning period and Party Conference
season she has only had had two and you
could tell uh that the response from the
conservative Ventures while she was
responding to those questions wasn't as
warm and supportive as you might expect
from a prime minister's second ever PM
Keys then we had this meeting of the the
1922 Committee of of back bench MPS
which by all accounts uh was explosive
should we say uh that some quotes saying
that it was the mood was funeral uh some
people saying there's a quote there
saying that it was worse than anything
uh that happened in that meeting under
Theresa May I remember the endless 1922
committee meetings under May where they
tried to sort of get rid of her and um
and she actually had trouble with her
adventures and um
but you've also got Robert halfen who's
a very well respected uh senior
conservative who's been running the
education Select Committee for many many
years saying that she's basically
trashed a decade's worth of conservative
working uh conservativism
um basically the the mood is that she
has managed to destroy 12 years of of
their record so it's not great I should
say that's a quite an achievement in uh
just about a month or non-achievement
Andrew how much trouble do you assess
her to be in let's look at the guardian
truss faces new Peril as Tories go on
the attack over economy it seems that
there is deep deep anger within the
party and deep deep Rifts
uh there's no doubt this is a disastrous
beginning for a Premiership uh normally
a new prime minister has a honeymoon
period this is
um anything but it's a nightmare for her
uh the bank of England had to step in
again today to uh in the guilts market
because interest rates have started
going up again found on in in trouble
but what I think is beginning to emerge
is there's increasing pressure on her
now and her Chancellor causing quieting
who was by the way supposed to be
addressing the 22 tonight but she
stepped in to do it instead hoping that
by speaking as prime minister with the
authority of the the prime minister's
office it would calm the nerves well
that didn't work did it
um but she there is pressure now it
seems for them to delay these tax cuts
not least because she said in primes's
questions today absolutely no to any
spending cuts now that's what she said
in her um conservative leadership
campaign but there were some audible
gasps because how then is she going to
pay
um for the tax cuts because there's it's
estimated there's going to be needed 65
billion pounds worth of potential Cuts
so is she now going to delay the the uh
the corporation tax rise for instance
was to be canceled is that now going to
be delayed
um will they possibly delay the cut in
basic rate of income tax due to coming
next April perhaps today at six months
perhaps today a year these are all
things we understand are now being
talked about not just by Tory MPS but by
people close to the Prime Minister she
knows she's in trouble the markets are
still very uncertain and the pound is
unstable so she's got they've got to do
something now to steady the nerves and I
don't think she's been helped actually
by Andrew Bailey the governor of the
bank of England there's a lot of anger
on the Tory benches about him
particularly comments yesterday saying
that the pensions industry's got three
days to get its act together and that's
it the bank then withdraws public
support uh uh and then it appears that
there was some rowing back on that so
there's not even Clarity coming out of
the bank of England so it's a complete
Hall it's to be honest it's a right mess
and I was in the comments this morning
talking to Tory MP's newtonous is an
understatement yeah so the options uh
let's look at the mirror well the mirror
sums them up really uh you turn or you
go do you agree with that Rachel if
she's not going to go for spending cuts
then the tax cuts have to go
uh the tax cuts May well end up going
some of them have have gone already the
scrapping the top rate of tax was uh it
was one of the first things to go I
think the trouble is that it's not just
about the unfunded tax cards it if you
look at what happened with the the mini
budget against a backdrop of huge
volatility anyway due to global forces
due to Rising inflation uh all over the
world due to
um the UK economy in particular and and
how Reliant we've been on on cheats debt
uh for the last decade
um there were a lot of forces not in the
government favor and the markets knew
that there was going to be this
announcement of an energy price Breeze
this guarantee because that was widely
trade trailed over the summer and it was
obvious that whoever was was prime
minister uh was going to have to do
something about Rising energy costs then
we got all of these extra unfunded tax
cuts kind of thrown in and what that
basically said to the markets was you
can't trust these people they haven't
even bothered to do the the spending
calculations of how they're going to pay
for all of this they are living in a
economic Fantasy Land uh and therefore
get your money out while you still can
which is essentially what's happened
over the last couple of of weeks now the
danger is that even if those tax cuts
are reversed and we go back to a
position before the mini budget but we
try and do the energy price guarantee
but none of the extra staff the global
markets will still look at the situation
and go yeah we still don't trust you we
still don't know it's all about
credibility
yeah and therefore UK debt remains very
expensive you still have the problems
with pensions you still have the
problems with mortgages so she's in this
very difficult position where even the
reversals might not be enough to save
her in terms of global economics and
they would be political suicide well
let's talk about that political suicide
Andrew because sooner you turn or you go
isn't it you turn and you might have to
go as well Financial Times trust faces
mounting Tory pressure to rewrite
unfunded tax cut plans well you know
let's imagine let's expect that that
does happen doesn't at least the
chancellor have to go is is mini budgets
or not budget is blown up in his face
I I think it would make the Chancellor's
position untenable
um he uh it would cause serious problems
for her too as prime minister because
look she signed off this budget
um she and quasi quite uh did not
discuss the top rate and top-rate
attacks with the cabinet we know that I
don't think they discussed many of the
major tax cuts uh with the cabinet so
they own it and this is what's really
infuriating a lot of Tory MPS and and no
doubt
um people who are trying to sort out
their mortgages look interest rates
dermit were going up anyway they're much
higher in the United States than they
are in Britain they were going to go up
here but because of the chaotic reaction
in the markets to that mini budget those
interest rate Rises now are being owned
by Liz truss and the chancellor the
voters will now associate them with the
reason why their mortgages are going up
that's why they've got such a big
political problem and I can remember
back in 1992 after black Wednesday when
interest rates sword to try to protect
uh the the the pound after we came
tumbling out of the exchange rate
mechanism uh and lots of people's homes
were repossessed and the and Tori and
voters did not forgive the Tories for
that and if repossession start to
increase in people's barbecues now start
to go up dramatically which we know they
are even though those interest rates
were going to go up because they're
going up all around the world from
altering them to Aberdeen to Arkansas in
the United States because of that mini
budget because of the way the markets
reacted to it and quasi-guarding's glad
he was going to cut taxes again the
following year
um the Tories are being blamed fairly
and squarely for those Rises and that's
what's called such
political turmoil it sticks a nice
alliteration there Andrew
um so Rachel what what are the Tory MPS
do though because the Metro's got it
here I think we more or less know it
from the bowling blue wall Falls
basically if they were a general
election now or indeed as it stands in a
few months time dozens scores maybe
hundreds of them lose their seats do
they I mean this is the calculation do
we stay with this prime minister do we
try and get some kind of Coronation or
do we turkeys vote for Christmas
it's a it's a really interesting bind
that the conservative party finds itself
at them at the moment especially because
they have ostensibly a majority of 80
odd seeds uh and yet they are that
they're electoral prospects are looking
worse by the day by the by the hour I
think this poll is worth looking at
specifically we've had some some polls
showing some quite astounding labor lead
of you know 33 points ahead of the Tory
sort of bigger than the
um the 1997 labor election Victory this
one um that's on the front of the Metro
is specifically looking at blue wall Z
so seats that have traditionally
historically been very very very safe
conservative indeed and it's showing
that labor has a 13-point lead in those
seats as well so basically it's not just
the red wall seats that Boris Johnson
won in in 2019 it's all Tories you have
to be very worried now
um they are limited in in their ability
to get rid it of the Liz trust so soon
after appointing her there is some talk
that some conservative MPS are so
worried about this that they might you
know work on the basis that I'm going to
lose my seat anyway let's vote for a
general election now let's have a vote
of no confidence in this government
because you know it'll limit the damage
to the party I don't really see that
being very likely I think generally MPS
don't like to vote for things that might
personally mean they'll be out of a job
in six weeks it would be quite something
but I think I think the chances of
defections though of uh dissatisfied
conservative MPS thinking about moving
over to labor you might get a few high
profile examples of that that's more
like anything can happen listen we've
got to got to take a break uh Rachel
Andrew thank you very much indeed for
the time being uh because coming up next
uh change the subject why Queen Consul
Camilla could have to swap her crown
because of the controversial Diamond
stay with us
[Music]
thank you
you're very welcome back you're watching
the Press preview with me now is the
senior associate editor of the new
Statesman Rachel canliff and the
consultant editor of the Daily Mail
Andrew Pierce and uh we're gonna have a
look at this story right now on the
front of your paper Andrew The Daily
Mail could Camilla have to swap her
crown plans for new Queen consort to
wear 105 carat Kohinoor Diamond maybe
shelved because of political
sensitivities and this is by uh your
Royal editor Rebecca English show what's
it about
it's a fascinating story Dermot this um
diamond is one of the most valuable and
uh largest in the world it used to be in
the possession of India but after the
annexation of Punjab in 1849 to part of
the British Empire of course then it
came to Britain it was seeded to Queen
Victoria she wore it in a brooch uh it's
only ever been worn by female members of
the royal family so in 1901 when Edward
VII comes the throne his Queen Alexandra
wears it 1911 when George V
um goes to the throne Queen it's Queen
Mary and then of course in 1937 at the
coronation of George VI the Queens the
late Queen's father the queen queen
mother wore it and then at the Queen's
coronation in 53 the queen mother wore
it again now the Indian politicians are
saying if it's worn again in the crown
by the queen consort Camilla it will
remind people of Empire
um the Raj imperialism and their effect
to be they're saying we don't want you
to now Britain is trying to do a major
trade deal with India post brexit post
EU it was going pretty well but it seems
the Home Secretary Sarah Braverman has
messed things up a bit because she
suggested Indian uh Indian people who
come here often are the ones who
overstay they're welcome the most that's
gone down very badly in India so the
trader we thought was about to be signed
is now looking a bit more uncertain but
this is which has the potential to cause
a diplomatic growl so the idea is that
the diamond the crown it's on show in
the Tower of London in the Showcase with
a lot of the other crown jewels but the
diamond can be detached from the crown
so Camilla could wear the crown but
without the diamond do you reckon that's
a good compromise Andrew what do you
think personally you reckon that'll work
I think it will and I think it will work
very well and it will um and of course I
would be more than I would be amazed if
the Indian Prime Minister the president
aren't at the coronation of Charles III
and queen Camilla okay and quick thought
on it Rachel very quick
I just think this is one of the the
benefits of having a royal family which
is that when there are political
tensions uh between political leaders
you can have your your world family step
in and make a very symbolic
statesman-like gesture such as not using
this diamond because it's a sensitive uh
sensitive artifact it's a very sensitive
time and smooth over political tensions
okay I said very quick um thank you very
much dude for that